près des difficultés également de
l'industrie du téléphone qui supprime
des milliers d'emplois quinze mille dix
6,8310 les syndicats qui ont lancé une
semaine d'actions et pourtant le chef de
l'état avait déclaré les dernières que
ce serait un scandale s'il se produisait
une crise dans la téléphonie
cette industrie d'inutiles ayant été
développé en france dans des proportions
massif
il n'est qu'à rappeler ces chiffres 16
millions d'abonnés au téléphone en 80
une cabine téléphonique au moins par
commune alors pourquoi en quête de
christian mary mono les syndicats ont
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé
6000 suppressions d'emplois en deux ans
quinze mille d'ici et 1983
alors que l'industrie du téléphone
emploie soixante sept mille personnes
la raison le choix industriels et
télécommunications en matière de
centrales téléphoniques ici à centrale
électro mécaniques avec son cliquetis
caractéristiques ils équipent la
majorité des 103 en france qui vous
permettent de joindre à chaque instant
votre correspondre depuis 77 les
centraux sont progressivement de type
temporel comme celui ci les
communications sont meilleurs plus
rapide plus nombreuses
le fils de cuivre est remplacé par ce
composant électronique au lieu de
l'électricité c'est de la lumière qui
circulent la différence
une personne seulement est nécessaire au
lieu de trois pour fabriquer les
systèmes temporel un système où nous
sommes actuellement les meilleurs du
monde
le chiffre d'affaires augmente la
productivité aussi mais pas l'emploi 40
constructeur existe en france mais trois
se partagent l'essentiel du marché du
téléphone
thomson csf site alcatel cgct la filiale
française itt était le chiffre
d'affaires de l'industrie le téléphone
s'élève à 12 milliards de francs dont
12% l'exportation ce qui nous place au
7e rang mondial difficile d'atteindre
l'objectif 1982 30% chiffre fixé par le
ministère la téléphonie française aborde
un virage important
elle constitue une des priorités du 8e
plan avec la télématique les satellites
les fibres optiques et l'utilisation de
votre téléphone
au téléphone lui aussi va subir des
modifications lui et dessiner plus
élaboré et à touches digital la
recherche de votre correspondant
facilité c'est très lu airs classiques
que vous connaissez tous disparaîtra
progressivement au profit de cet
annuaire électronique 1982 première
expérimentation en ille-et-vilaine 250
mille abonnés si la décision du
gouvernement intervient en 1992 vous
saurez 30 millions d'abonnés à
bénéficier de cet annuaire électronique
et cet annuaire sera compris dans le
prix de l'abonnement
une étude intéressante du cercle centre
d'études